well rhiannon mills is outside
parliament for us right now and um
you could sort of see on prince
charles's face i think as he as he
delivered those lines actually i i
wonder if he wonders whether the queen
will be able to attend these events
she's clearly looking forward to them
but as we see the monarchy is flexing
and other people are coming in to assist
her
at the moment as her mobility falters
i think today was was again a reminder
of how
over the years we have become so used to
her majesty the queen
carrying out her public services and
duties
and enjoying relatively good health and
yet now we have a monarch who herself
has admitted in recent weeks and months
that she is having
trouble standing and walking and
as a result of that the royal family the
palace and also the public are going to
have to get used to seeing younger mems
the royal family increasingly stepping
up and taking on some of her
responsibilities and i think yes we will
see that around the platinum jubilee
weekend but if we look at today it was a
hugely
symbolic moment and i think it will be
seen as one of those
defining moments for the monarchy when
historians look back at these twilight
years of this elizabethan age there has
been this softly softly approach to
transition and yes we have seen younger
members of the royal family already
stepping up and helping the queen things
like prince charles laying her wreath at
the cenotaph for remembrance sunday
other mem's royal family carrying out
investitures and also doing those
overseas tours on her behalf but today
was the first time that really we've
seen younger members of the family
taking on what is a key part of her
constitutional role and the decision for
that will not have been taken lightly
literally until the 11th hour we were
told that the queen herself wanted to
come she planned to come but as i think
we've seen in recent weeks when it's
come to things like the commonwealth day
service the maundy service events where
she would have to walk great distances
or sit for a long time and this again
would have been one of them
practicalities simply had to kick in and
that's what's happened
with this one and it was always going to
be interesting for constitutional
experts and the like likes of you and i
to see exactly how the queen wanted this
to play out and i think
those constitutional experts some of
them were
puzzled and surprised by the fact that
she decided to use that letter's patent
so that
change in the rules
to mean that two councillors of state so
her son and grandson would carry out the
responsibilities today but that
ultimately is the way that she decided
it should be and we are seeing the
constitution flex and change
to deal with an ageing monarch although
the palace very keen to point out that
this is not a monarch who is looking at
abdicating if you look at her accession
day speech that she made her accession
day message that she delivered
in february this year to start the
platinum jubilee year once again she
reaffirmed her commitment to serving her
country and the commonwealth but today
she has handed over
maybe just for this year we're going to
have to wait and see but that important
constitutional role of making sure that
the parliamentary session could still
get underway despite the fact that she
wasn't able to appear
here in person but yeah the palace very
clearly also saying that yes she's
having trouble with her mobility but it
is still going to be the queen who will
have a virtual session with privy
council this week it's still going to be
the queen who is going to speak to her
prime minister and ultimately it was her
son and her grandson who were jointly
opening parliament today however i think
the problem is and for those who talk
about this being a regency a prince
regent situation and everything but name
the optics today seeing prince charles
front and center
it did look more like a regency
situation than i suspect the palace
wouldn't necessarily want to but
ultimately that was how the ceremony
played out and the palace stressing that
she is still very much in charge and
certainly when it comes to platinum
jubilee
she will still be the star of
proceedings
okay rhiannon thank you very much